i can finally declare a sort of
victory because i sort of guessed the
last woke commercial correctly
i didn't say it because i was so
engrossed in it but i actually did guess
it
so i'm gonna just take that because i've
gotten all the other ones wrong i think
i'm what like one
one in ten right now something like that
we've got a new slew
of woke commercials that you the viewers
have sent into us
these are all on one of my favorite
themes the masks
we just had a study come out of denmark
that the masks don't protect
people who wear them from the virus
which we all know from the very
beginning
doesn't stop commercials from virtue
signaling on the question of masks first
i would like to mention that this video
is sponsored by my bookie the best place
to place
bets on sports and political events of
all kinds
more on them later first let's roll the
tape
this is not new
this has happened before in every
downturn
and disaster in history gender equality
has been set back
as women have stepped forward oh i
thought this is not new with the masks
but now it's a feminist
heavy cost more of the frontline care
more the pay cuts more of the jobs lost
more of the responsibilities at home
keeping them from going back to paid
work
these times are not unprecedented
but they give us another chance for
equality if we all choose to step
forward as equals
i have no idea equal higher selection
[Music]
model equal do equal choose
equal like a credit card i don't know
i'm just like hail mary it's like a
credit card i don't know
for an equal future
ah procter gamble wait procter gamble
gillette also i guess like all those
companies
you know it was a total hail mary when i
said credit card because it just had the
font that you see in credit card
commercials
man png is really what they must have
done
like three of the woke commercials we've
only done what 11 of them or something
wow in every downturn gender equality
has been set back they also have this
sleight of hand
where they were pretending and i've seen
a lot of left wingers do this
that mass public mask wearing
has been a common thing in american
history they say that this happened
like in the various pandemics we've had
it's just not true this is a cultural
mania we've never had this kind of
widespread masking
but then they shifted it to feminism
because it's not all
all of these kind of manias are not
about science and they're not about
medicine
they're all about leftist ideology okay
well
i blew that one had no idea whatsoever i
can't even pretend like i thought of it
let's try the next one
[Music]
it's gonna be a maybe a fashion one
because these are all kind of colorful
nice masks like the masks are really
front and center now let's protect carry
[Music]
see it being like a like a dentist like
a dental thing or like a
clothing thing no uber
uber
nothing at all i this is like i actually
want to be graded on a curve here
because there are a few commercials like
this i remember the last one we did
it was it was an oreo it was a gay oreos
commercial
and there would have been very little in
this whole commercial to to let you know
that except
at one moment they actually showed an
oreo so i like i could have picked up on
that
that was my fault in this one there was
absolutely nothing in the commercial
that could possibly have let me know
that this was an uber commercial i
actually can't
i don't feel bad about getting that
wrong i want that taken off my
score card but i can't okay one and two
one and two glad i didn't make any bets
on that one
and i could though make some bets at my
bookie that would be a lot more fun it
is betting season over at my bookie
as if you weren't already way too into
politics right now
with my bookie you can bet on things
like i can't believe i'm saying this
the 2024 u.s presidential election
winner
we're not even done with the 2020
election and we're already going on to
2024.
you can bet on will it be aoc oh
will it be ted cruz that'd be pretty
good would it be kanye west yeah i'm
actually i'm actually into that would it
be elon musk
maybe i don't know you can place your
bets now nothing makes an event more
exciting than putting some money on it
make it interesting
with sports and election season in full
swing now is the time to try your hand
whether you've been betting for years or
you're ready to play for the first time
my bookie is your go-to this season with
the biggest online selection of bets and
props
my bookie has made it simple to win and
easy to withdraw your cash all right i'm
putting my money on cruz i can't wait
for that maybe i'll head on over to my
bookie
maybe i'll maybe i'll bet it on a
verdict podcast episode
head on over there create an account
just use the promo code knollskinnerwlis
to claim your 100 deposit match all the
way up to a thousand dollars that means
if you put a hundred dollars in
it will give you another hundred dollars
it's an easy way to jump start your
bankroll nfl nba mlb everything else
they've got it all on tap
and it is never too late to get started
on your winning
season only at my bookie
okay the next two videos my producers
tell me
are public service announcements for the
masks
so we already know what they're selling
it's a psa they're trying to get people
to mask up
they have asked me to try to guess which
states put out the psa
let's try
[Music]
should not be a political yeah this
hundreds of millions of people wearing
this crazy thing on their face that
shouldn't be political
it's protective it's a barrier
okay they're appealing to the military
so it's probably not new york and
california i'm going to guess at least
it's a more conservative state
like a purple to a red state this fourth
of july don't accidentally kill someone
wear a mask state of war i was well
i was going to say i was totally wrong
because oregon is so blue but that's not
actually true
uh portland is extremely blue but the
rest of oregon is actually pretty red
still pretty wrong if i i would have
guessed more of a kind of toss-up state
like a north carolina
or a pennsylvania or a michigan not
oregon i will and to i will take the
sort of honorable thing and take the
laws let's try one more can i redeem
myself
i work out every day kovid won't kill me
24. kovid won't kill me i have
antibodies
kovid won't kill him okay this one's
pretty hysterical i mean this one's
pretty alarmist
so i'm going to say maybe more new york
won't kill me but i haven't gotten it
yet covered this is gonna be a blue
stick covered won't kill me
like their last words don't let them be
yours
be new york tough and smart socially
distant okay
wear a mask okay hey good all right i
got it you can take the boy out of new
york you cannot take
the new york out of the boy i'm glad
that i can still speak
new york fluently and and at least get
one of these
right post other woke commercials and
videos that you want me to review
in the comments section i will try to
increase my success rate
we'll see you at the next one
[Music]
you